the Ukrainian drone attack on the port
city of sevastopol was the home of the
Russian Black Sea Fleet and although
they've destroyed a lot of oil it will
have significant consequences for the
for the war this seems to follow Russia
targeting uh Kiev overnight on Thursday
which was the first time they've
attacked keebs for in 51 days the
Russian barrage of 23 missiles Ukraine
claims to shut down 21 of them but
actually there were 21 25 civilians
killed and at the point being really
that the war in Ukraine despite falling
off the media attention the last few
days it's very busy on the ground if we
look at the area of intense fighting
that's still around back moot the area
of back moot is now 87 taken by the
Wagner group uh and the but the war
grinds on away from that front line
though most of the fighting is actually
focused more on preparations for the
spring offensive down in Crimea the
Russian yard there's a massive storage
yard there for equipment has been
emptied of its armored personnel
carriers and its tanks the is aparicha
nuclear facility the Russians have been
sandbacking bagging defensive positions
there which is very worrying because
they will become targets come any form
of uh counter-offensive fortunately the
main reactor is hardened so that looks
like it's going to be safe to the east
of zaparita all way along this line the
Russians have been digging extensive
trenches 120 kilometers of them in
layered defense some of the trenches are
visible from space and they're also
putting in Dragon's Teeth we haven't
seen those since the second world war
about a meter tall their pyramid-shaped
concrete designed to slow down tanks and
Russians have been increasing shelling
all the way across this front line from
a Ukrainian perspective the 14
000 Ukrainian troops that have been
trained in the UK are all now back in
Ukraine and that's only the uh the ones
that have been trained in the UK or lots
of other nations also providing trained
soldiers and in the NATO Secretary
General only this week has also
announced that 98 of the aid that was
the being asked for ready for the spring
offensive has now been delivered that's
over 1500 armored vehicles 230 tanks and
an absolute vast quantities of
ammunition but returning to that strike
on the sevastopol oil facility this was
not an isolated attack this is all part
of coordinated Ukraine action the spring
storm is coming